rassemblés autour de la table les
chroniqueurs d'antisèches prépare
l'émission du soir sur marmite fm avec
quelques minutes de la prise d'antenne
les dernières consignes sont données
pour romain nouveau dans l'émission ses
relectures de chronique je suis pas
forcément invité de la radio donc doit
penser radio je dois penser aussi public
parce que ça doit être accessible pour
les personnes forcément kuti qui
écoutent l'émission et qui sont pas
forcément ni des agrégés de philo animé
grand cinéphile
au final c'est ce qu'ont fait aussi avec
nos chroniques on fait avec ce qu'on
aime on fait avec ce qu'on fait avec ce
qu'on est il est 20 heures c'est l'heure
de l'antisèche sur marmite fm
bonjour à tous la sonnerie qui retentit
on la baisse un petit peu bienvenue sur
marmite fm le 88.4 vous êtes dans le
l'antisèche les missions que personne ne
sèche en résille on trouve julien
denervaud à la réalisation et
l'animation à travers la vitre son rôle
est de créer une énergie entre les
chroniqueurs et les invités pour avoir
intox chaud avec du rire de la bonne
humeur et des informations positives à
transmettre à l'auditeur dans le tissage
tu peux découvrir plein de trucs tu peux
tu peux vraiment découvrir des artistes
locaux
ça c'est vraiment la preuve l'objectif
numéro 1 tu peux aussi apprendre plus
sur des gens plus connus comme gérard
majax été menée dans l'émission ou
encore
les vertes qu'on aura la
semaine prochaine tu peux aussi
apprendre des trucs à raconter à la
bastide à café au programme de
l'émission les questions de marie les
instruments insolites de kevin ou encore
la philo pop de romain clerc passe à
l'antenne depuis deux ans et chaque
mercredi c'est toujours le même plaisir
c'est nos missions on se prend pas la
tête
où on pose son cerveau pendant deux
minutes et juste on s'amuse et en fait
on se rend compte que même imposant son
cerveau on peut apprendre plein de trucs
et c'est ça qui est super c'est la
quatrième saison pour antisèches qui
compte à son actif 117 émission de talk
show est à retrouver sur le 88.4 ou en
podcast sur le site de marmites fm